what's going on everyone it is axl beats
here for anime uproar and today we have
another exciting entry into the jujutsu
kaizen manga with this chapter we have
officially entered the culling game and
i can't even begin to explain how
excited i am because i think this is
going to get wild very very fast if you
enjoy this video and you want to see
more jiu jitsu kaizen content on this
channel remember to leave a like as well
as a comment down below it only takes a
second but it is really helpful with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you do so by
clicking that bell and selecting all
notifications you can also follow anime
uproar on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt of course this video will
contain jiu jitsu kaizen manga spoilers
as we are talking about the latest
developments in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned now before we get into it the
chapter previous was a little bit slow
so we skipped the week but i do want to
cover it briefly here chapter 159 was
called judgment and much like how 158
introduced us to hajime a little bit
this chapter 159 introduced us to hiromi
now hajime seemed to be a bit of a
cold-blooded killer but hiromi seems to
at least have some extent of a good
person within himself at the very least
he used to deeply value justice while at
the same time being disillusioned with
the law system in japan
hiromi was a criminal defense lawyer and
while i don't think that his backstory
will be super vital going forward we do
get a look at one of his cases where he
defended an innocent man at first he
actually won the case but upon it being
appealed the man ended up being found
guilty regardless he explained that he
can never really ignore things that he
believes to be wrong and when he
realizes that his client was found
guilty before the trial even started
again despite being innocent hiromi goes
on a rampage summoning a cursed spirit
as the chapter closes with a note that
the hammer of wrath was opened within
the courtroom so a few things to note
here firstly while hiromi is definitely
violent and dangerous as i mentioned
earlier his heart at least used to be in
the right place whether or not he will
continue to fight for justice is another
matter after realizing the corruption of
japan's legal system especially in a
post-culling game world honestly while
not much happened in this chapter it
really connected with me as well as the
town this story takes place in is
actually the one that i lived in when i
was in japan and while i was there i
always heard stories from people about
how i needed to be extra careful about
where i was and when not because the
city was particularly dangerous because
it absolutely wasn't however japan's
legal system has something like a 99
conviction rating the reason their crime
stats are always so low
is because whoever is suspected of a
crime tends to be found guilty of that
crime regardless of the reality of the
situation so i can definitely understand
being uncomfortable with that situation
pretty well but i can't even begin to
imagine how frustrating it would be for
a criminal defense lawyer who feels a
strong need to do the right thing
i can totally understand how someone in
that position might snap in the way that
hiromi does on to the current chapter
though that being chapter 160 entitled
colony we open up with a chilling image
of kenjaku the cursed spirit inhabiting
suguru ghetto's body looking down on a
woman and apologizing from within an
entirely dark realm the woman is
actually yugi's friend sasuke from the
occult club way back at the start of the
series and i kind of love that she's
back i don't particularly think that the
series was lacking for not having her in
it but i always did find it a little bit
weird that we were introduced to yuji's
friends only for them to vanish almost
immediately and never matter again
anyways kanjaku explains that he set up
a barrier around her area and that the
whole place will become a brutal
battleground in the near future
apparently he chose this area because it
was close to an old execution ground and
i'm kind of wondering if this was where
sukuna was killed or maybe even where
the original kenjaku was killed that
said the barrier seems to be very
difficult for him to put up so he can't
place conditions himself
anyone within the barrier will get one
chance to leave and i'm assuming that by
having this restriction the barrier will
actually be made much stronger than it
would be otherwise similar to how saying
a barrier is only working for gojo would
make it stronger against gojo
specifically i am more than sure that if
kenjaku had it his way he would have
wanted to keep all of the non-sorcerers
within it to die but it seems like he
can't quite do that so instead he simply
offers sasuke the opportunity to be
outside of the barrier when she wakes up
and obviously she chooses to get the
hell out of there but as kanjaku leads
her out of the dark dream realm we see
massive curses in the background and
what might be one of the most
interesting lines of the entire chapter
as he thanks her for getting along with
his son now if you remember from chapter
143 we saw that yuji's mom was also
inhabited by kenjaku this is crazy to me
like i am dying to see what this is all
about when did he take her over how does
being the child of a curse affect yuji
how is it affecting sukuna and finally
with this new edition of information
why does kenjaku still seem to care
about yuji at least enough to thank
sasuke for being his friend it is always
interesting when the big bad is a
protagonist's parent but i don't think
i've ever seen it where the big bad in
those situations is one that can
constantly switch bodies the closest
thing i can really think of is the 2003
version of fullmetal alchemist where
hohenheim sort of did the same thing but
he wasn't really the big bad in that
story he just kind of was very much tied
to the big bad either way makes for a
great plot point sasuke wakes up outside
of the barrier with the other member of
the occult club and it seems like
everyone here had the same experience
but the only one that kenjaku thanked
was her which understandably leaves her
pretty confused from here we cut to the
main group and they are looking for
angel in the list of players however she
doesn't seem to be using her real name
angel for those who don't remember is
the woman who's supposed to be able to
free gojo but the only hint that they
really have to go off is that she's in
colony too and they will know her when
they see her and that's not a whole lot
to work with however they really can't
just wait for things to sort themselves
out the time has come where they have to
join the game and the plan is that yuji
and megami will go to colony 1 while
panda and hikari will go to colony 2.
meanwhile kirana will stay on the
outskirts acting as communication akari
wants to go to colony 2 because that's
where hajime is supposed to be and the
strongest person should probably go deal
with the strongest opponent
i think yuji and hiromi should be able
to get along if they meet both of them
have a pretty strong sense of right and
wrong but i'm wondering if hiromi is
just a little bit too far gone at this
point to actually work with anyone on
the other hand with how quick to
violence hikari is and how itching
hajime is for a fight i don't think that
that's gonna go quite as smoothly as
they might hope
and yeah i'm sure that hikari is very
very strong but will he be able to deal
with a man literally in the process of
hunting down sukuna
i'm not sure about that one honestly
with that said though we finally see our
lads approaching the barriers and
officially declaring that they are going
to enter the colonies and with that
declaration of determination the chapter
comes to a close as the narrator says
that it is time to cross into the depths
of hades itself and the culling game
begins
this arc is going to be crazy i'm
expecting so many insane battles i have
so many massive questions that i need
the answers to like the issue of kenjoku
and yuji who this angel girl is and how
she will help gojo how our lads are
going to deal with the murderous hajime
and hiromi and now that sukhuna is in a
different colony what will ultimately
lead him into contact with hajime
so many huge things are coming this way
and i cannot wait but let me know your
own thoughts in the comments down below
like i said i am super stoked for this
arc but what do you think now that the
cullen game is starting what do you
think is going to happen and what do you
want to see happen
either way i'll be here covering the ark
entirely for you so be sure to subscribe
to anime uproar and ring that bell so
you don't miss any of our videos coming
your way and if you enjoyed this video
remember to leave a like and comment
down below to help us with the youtube
algorithm so we can keep making content
for you finally if you'd like you can
follow anime uproar over on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt i want to
give a big thank you to all of our
patrons over on patreon who allow videos
like this to be possible especially the
patron of legend the one who's
acknowledged by lord twego himself alpha
sigma as well are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all clans in
grata patahafa al-jatal hinokami and
water the toasted chi the spike 8227
corey mcgowan dylan isadore spidey life
tinnell tungsten tarcus baked buddhist
cody hebert and monkey d quilly finally
our pro hero tier patrons gilgamesh the
red-haired raven anel cruz rathwin de
ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted noted fat boy games
and soul rise slice and dice if you
enjoy our work or maybe think we just
offer a little bit of extra enjoyment in
your day to day life please consider
going to patreon.com anime uproar and
supporting the channel for as little as
one dollar you will get your name
featured in future videos as well as
have access to our exclusive patron only
discord you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe option but
whichever way you support us you will
get these same great benefits thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time stay excellent
[Music]
okay